all right what's going on guys this is
rob and in this video i want to do
something a little bit dangerous
i want to have this i want to throw this
theory out here that one division
may or may not necessarily lead to
mutants but that one division is going
to lead to
a government program that's designed to
contain and control
the mutant threat this program is called
project wide awake and tyler hayward
from sword will be the one that
spearheads it over on comics explain at
the time you're watching this video i
will have had a video on that channel
that came out on monday
called project wide awake explains and
it basically breaks down the entire
project in a far more nuanced way than
what we're gonna do here right i
basically give you like the whole the
whole history of it and make you an
expert on it in like 20 minutes
but to give you guys a quick and dirty
explanation here project wide awake came
after the introduction of adam brashear
also known as the blue marvel and adam
beshear was the first major superhero to
operate inside the united states but his
operations as a superhero coincided with
the civil rights movement and when it
was learned that adam berscher was a
black man the concern of the federal
government is
well this guy can obviously withstand
like atomic bombs hydrogen bombs things
like that
what happens if he takes all that power
and decides to target us this led into a
whole series of discussions about what
happens as somebody out there with an
extraordinary power that we cannot
control
turns out to be a communist or turns out
to be some kind of person that wants to
destroy the federal government for
whatever reason and so the result of
this is
project wide awake came into existence
now it also coincided with the idea of
like mutants
basically the the notion that people out
there had incredible powers that range
from everything from telepathy and
telekinesis all the way up to somebody
like magneto who can manipulate the
entire electromagnetic spectrum
and so in essence the goal of project
wide awake was contain
and control now if you look at wanda
vision you look at sword you look at
everything going on not even looking at
like wanda herself but the other side of
the equation tyler hayward and all those
guys
sword in the marvel cinematic universe
stands for sentient weapon
observation and response department
right meaning that they are an
organization out there that functions
for the purpose of analyzing
and monitoring various people out there
that have extraordinary powers
and then responding to them right so
like if somebody out there has the
ability to warp reality finding a way to
be able to curtail that threat which is
particularly important
when you look at the character of white
vision now the reality of this is that
tyler hayward will most likely end up
becoming some kind of bolivar
trask-esque character in the sense that
in the original project wide awake
bolivar trask was the guy who developed
this sentinel program that would
basically
allow the federal government to develop
these giant robots that would be able to
contain and control mutants now the
truth is that the robots did have their
limitations
against somebody like magneto who could
control the electromagnetic spectrum
metallic robots
didn't really serve any useful purpose
and in fact he could just let off a
massive emp like he did back in the day
and basically take out all the power on
earth which is actually what he did at
one point in the comics but in response
to that you saw bolivar trask and even
after bolivar trask stephen lang who
received all the research from bolivar
trask you ended up seeing him grab a
whole bunch of the information and then
start creating things like plastic
signals these settles that were made of
hard plastics that were strong enough to
take out
a lot of powerful heroes they didn't
really succumb to the power of somebody
like magneto and so what this basically
means is that tyler hayward will likely
end up becoming
a bolivar trask like character and that
one division itself will end up
establishing the commission
on superhuman activities now the csa is
not part and parcel to
project wide awake it's a wholly
separate entity but it does exactly what
its name sounds like it's there to
monitor superhuman activities and to
make sure that they fall
in line with the charter of like federal
laws and different things like that and
even to strip people of their power for
example
the csa and the comics took away steve
rogers from being captain america
because the argument was they owned what
was in effect the copyright to captain
america and they could make anybody
captain america they wanted to be and
they got rid of steve rogers and
replaced them with somebody else but the
csa
will basically lead to the launch of
project wide awake which is a
multi-faceted intelligence gathering
apparatus with inside the united states
that involved everybody from the cia to
the fbi to state sheriff's office to
local law enforcement the national
security council the national security
adviser
even the president of the united states
was kind of part of it the whole point
was it was supposed to survive
any existing president and so the
president didn't necessarily have
absolute control over it instead
it was basically led by the national
security advisor henry peter gyrick who
is also in charge
of uh the operations of the entire
project but the important thing about
this and this this is what makes the
entire idea of project wide awake so
cool inside the marvel cinematic
universe is what would come
out of it so mutants are going to arrive
in the mcu we know that's going to
happen somewhere along the line and at
the outset you're going to see
early confrontations between mutants and
just regular humans because humans
aren't really going to understand them
or know where they're coming from and
because
people don't like change they're going
to be afraid that like their kids are
going to be mutants right and it's not
even necessarily the fact that they're
afraid that their kid might have the
power of flight they're afraid because
their kid might get mad at them
and suck out all the oxygen in the room
right or their kid might get mad at them
and wipe their minds of any knowledge
they've had of their life before and
have them spending the rest of their
lives walking around like cats right
that's
entirely possible when you're talking
about somebody with telepathy that kind
of stuff is not beyond the the realm of
possibility when it comes to those kinds
of powers and so mutants are going to
present the first credible threat to the
idea of project wide awake and to
humanity not only because of the powers
they have
but because there will be so many of
them right now if you look at the marvel
cinematic universe and you take into
account black widow
at most you have what the avengers and
the various people you've seen there you
have some villains like loki thunderbolt
ross who's going to become red hulk at
some point
you've got like the red room which was
basically you know russia's version of
weapons plus which led to the creation
of wolverine which is you know
the whole united states and canada's
department k project you have the winter
guard which was russia's version
of at least in the comics of the
avengers and the marvel cinematic
universe won't really be that way but
it'll just kind of be you know their
their own kind of superhero or or people
with superhuman abilities kind of doing
their own thing but you you have what is
in effect
a small group of people with powers
right the number of people who have
powers in the marvel cinematic universe
that operate on earth you can count on
maybe two and a half hands but then you
throw mutants into the mix and people
suddenly being born with powers well
then that number increases exponentially
because you'd have the number of people
increasing with powers at a geometric
rate that would lead to
project wide away taking on a whole new
form now the question becomes if that's
the case and if the whole idea here is
contain and control then what would be
the federal government's response to all
these different mutants and all these
different people with powers alright
well let's circle right back around
sword sentient weapon observation and
response department this basically means
that white vision is most likely
the first in a series of robots that
will become sentinels and that somewhere
along the line
they will develop nimrod and if they do
that the superheroes
are [ __ ] because nimrod is insane okay
let's talk about white vision for a
second white vision is a version of
vision
that basically is built off the existing
technology established by tony stark and
bruce banner we know that sword is going
to be limited in their capacity to do
that
assuming that they cannot get reid
richards from the fantastic four on
their side which means they're not gonna
have anybody on the same level of
intelligence as tony stark was so
they're basically operating with
second-hand information they can reverse
engineer it but only to a point right
it's the half-life effect they can't
create anything as great as what tony
stark did it'll only ever be half as
good and so because of that
white vision is basically operating
based on programming
instilled in him by sword and whatever
engineers they had working ultimately
white vision
will likely be defeated but this will
give sword their first attempt and and
basically a ton of information a ton of
data they can analyze
on how successful this attempt was and
facing off against
threats that exist out there people who
have superhuman powers from there
they will develop more information
they'll develop more robots they'll work
on more projects and they will expand
this over and over and over and over
again
until they come across something that's
capable of following the charter of
project wide awake which is
contain and control this will likely
come in the form of nimrod now those who
don't know nimrod was
a super advanced sentinel from the
future that had all kinds of different
abilities he could analyze you and
figure out what your weaknesses are and
use those against you he could analyze
your powers and find ways to neutralize
your powers before you could even use
them he had all kinds of crazy abilities
right he had the ability to like
heal himself from injuries so like a
robot version of a healing factor
more or less but he was designed to be a
one-man army you take an
army of those and you send them out
there it's going to lead to a whole host
of different problems but i think that's
the direction that one division is going
in as far as like the sword aspect goes
out of the events of wanda vision
is gonna come project wide awake
humanity waking up
so to speak to the various threats that
superhumans pose the tyler hayward is
gonna be the one that spearheads this
that there may actually be a bolivar
trask or steven lang or somebody out
there but it'll basically lead to a huge
intelligence operating apparatus out
there that exists for the purpose of
finding a way to contain and control
individuals out there that have
extraordinary powers which is gonna make
life an absolute nightmare for the
mutant population but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end make sure you guys check out our
videos on wandavision
theories easter eggs all that kind of
stuff and make sure you guys check out
the project wide awake explained video
over on comics explain so you can get a
far more nuanced and in-depth
explanation of how this whole thing
works and i will catch you guys later
peace